I couldn't get a job at an advertising
agency which was what I wanted to do and
I did a very successful campaign for a
store that was like a potpourri story
that that handled all sorts of fabulous
home decor and gifts and things like
that and it kind of made me overnight
and I got a lot of referrals from that
and then I started my business it was
called Linda limited that was a limited
name don't you think I have a much
bigger vision today and it wasn't so
hard they were very grateful I was cheap
or inexpensive and I produced and it
really never gotten my way until later
when I was in my early 20s I went on a
pitch to the International House of
Pancakes I went in and showed my
portfolio tried to get the business and
the man said to me you have to leave now
and I said why and he said I can't stand
to see a woman your age doing this it's
ridiculous it makes me extremely
uncomfortable I said okay of course I
wouldn't the car and cried I guess there
was nothing I could do about it you know
I I am Who I am but that was really the
only time that that happened now
throughout my life things have happened
certainly even employees of mind who
find it uncomfortable to answer to a
woman you know throughout life but
that's you know can't stand the heat you
get out of the kitchen it's nothing
nothing that believe me the positive
sides of being a woman in business are
far more important to my success I think
then the negative sides
being a good marketer is like being a
good friend a good friend listens
anticipates your needs I gives you more
than you thought you were getting its
and women listen we were bred to listen
because we raise our children and
fathers do too but there's a sensitivity
that women have so I think that women
make very good marketers I know a lot of
men that are good at marketing as well
but I think we have a special knack for
it and I think I'm a good friend if you
interviewed my friends I think they
would say I'm a good friend and I think
that's made me a good marketer too
we're so lucky we're doing very well
because I think we first of all we sell
food and people have to eat and also the
pistachio business is in 60 countries so
that helps because there are a few
places on the planet that are still
doing okay and like India is a huge
market for us but we've only have a two
percent you know share so we have a big
upside in China as well when when things
are going well people are happier when
people feel as though they're being
heard they're happier when they're part
of the solution they're happier when
they know the layoffs have already taken
place and their job is secure that helps
tremendously so and we have some
fabulous geniuses that work for us I
mean it's just great young energetic
people that are passionate about the
brand's passionate about what we do
giving back I think that's a big way
that we that people are drawn to our
company because that's a big part of
what who we are as a company we give
every employee a thousand dollars a year
to give away to charity as long as it's
a 501c3 we won't pay for uncle Harry's
hip replacement but we do and we ask
them if they can to give it to their
local community to their local church or
school or they know what's going wrong
in their community much more than we
would you know where we sit and so
that's exciting you know and then we
match funds up to a certain point and so
forth so I think people feel like
they're doing well by doing
you